i like to learn new ways to save money i
mean who doesn't like some extra cash in
their wallet but i wasn't always the
most frugal minimal or intentional
shopper actually quite the contrary so
in honor of my 29th birthday this month
i took some time to reminisce and look
back at how far i've come and remember
all the stupid financial decisions i
made so today i'm going to be sharing
with you my seven most dumbest purchases
that i made in my early 20s so if you've
made some financial mistakes in your
life don't worry you are not alone and
there is hope for you yet but before we
begin it would mean so much to me if you
would consider giving a thumbs up as a
birthday gift to me it really helps my
channel out a lot so thank you very much
and right off the bat let's start with
the most embarrassing one to me
number one is a gas stove and what's
wrong with purchasing a gas stove you
might ask well
maybe the fact that a you don't have gas
and b you don't have a home to put it in
yeah insert slapping face emoji right
now the story behind this one is because
it was a good deal my husband and i were
engaged and we did not live together
before we had gotten married and so come
black friday we were out shopping for
all the things that we thought we were
gonna need and there was just this
really good deal at best buy that if you
bought the refrigerator with the stove
and the microwave you got this like
awesome deal i could i could not pass it
by i had to save the money right and so
we ended up purchasing the combo we
ended up renting that location did not
have gas actually came with the
appliances so we didn't even need the
refrigerator we kept it because we liked
it and so we had two refrigerators at
that location and then we ended up
having to sell that range stove losing
money on it even more because by then it
had expired on its warranty and people
people didn't trust that it was actually
not used so
yeah that was stupid at that time i had
not learned the lesson that you save 100
of your money if you just don't buy that
good deal lesson learned
so i work as a registered nurse but when
i started off i was a cashier and i was
making almost minimum wage at seven
dollars and fifty cents at that time so
when i graduated and i finally got my
nursing job my pay tripled to 22 an hour
and you better believe i had some
lifestyle creep at that time i was
driving a pretty car it was a
convertible mitsubishi eclipse but it
had problems it would stall on me i had
to constantly be taking it to the
mechanic it leaked on the roof and so i
needed a new car in my mind i thought
i'm making this long commute to the city
to work i need a reliable car and what
better than a brand new car i ended up
financing a brand new car for twenty
three thousand dollars twenty three
something and when i ended up selling it
back i got back thirteen thousand
dollars i lost ten thousand dollars in
depreciation plus having that monthly
payment meant that i was making less
money to save
at the end of the month each month so it
was just a very dumb mistake
looking back i should have just
purchased a car that had been used that
had already had most of its value
depreciated and then i wouldn't have
that monthly payment so yeah that was a
very dumb mistake
and speaking of lifestyle creep
unfortunately my purchases did not stop
there as a nurse i worked 12 hour shifts
and even though i worked overtime most
of the time anyway that really meant
that i was working three to four days a
week and so i found myself with extra
time because i didn't have kids at that
time my husband was out working and i
had a new home to decorate and so
unfortunately that meant that every day
that i was off of work i was out in the
home decor shops i mean i'm telling you
that there must have not been a single
day that i was off of work and i was not
out shopping because it was fun and i
needed to decorate my home i must have
spent hundreds upon hundreds of dollars
on home decor and i'm not even talking
like furniture pieces i'm just talking
about little decor items like little
wall signs and things like that because
i had 10 pillows on our bed i kid you
not i counted them we had table runners
of different colors that had to match
the candle colors that had to match the
vases that had to match the flowers the
plastic fake flowers and all sorts of
things that i would swap out with each
season or every few weeks because i
wanted to just give a refresh oh my
goodness it is insane the amount of
stuff that i had just to decorate the
house and i had them boxed up in a
closet so that i could swap them out
continuously it was a never-ending cycle
it was excessive to say the least
and this is where it gets emotional i
had a relationship with god at that time
but i still had some wounds that i
needed to heal i had been deeply wounded
and used in the past and i felt a deep
desire to feel worthy to feel valuable
to feel beautiful and i had purchased so
much clothing so much makeup that i'm
saddened by this because at that time i
had no idea of the effect that my
purchases were causing on not only the
environment but the people behind it all
the exploitation of workers i had no
idea that people's lives have actually
been lost in bloodshed because of fast
fashion i will forever be grateful for
the documentary the true cost because it
changed my perspective on fashion
dramatically but at that time i had over
30 dresses and i was actually proud of
that because i had one dress for every
day of the month i had a huge makeup
chest that had all sorts of things with
contour palettes and fake lashes all
sorts of lipsticks i had a huge
assortment of nail polish and my clothes
actually took up two closets worth now
that i think about it i probably spent
thousands on fast fashion
this one i'm very ashamed about i
purchased real human hair extensions for
almost 500
because i wanted more volume
tell me why
why does a girl that has hair to her
waist need hair extensions that were
probably purchased from someone
somewhere around the world for a
miserable amount of money just to get by
so that i can feel pretty you see at
that time i did not love myself i had
been abused and i felt and believed that
i was unworthy i believed that i had to
earn love and i believed that if i
failed at something then i was a failure
and i was unworthy of love and so i felt
as though i had to put on this persona
put on this mask of perfection that
everything i did and was was perfect and
wonderful and that my life was perfect
and i was perfectly happy i was trying
to fill a void within myself but you see
i was approaching it from the wrong
direction from the outside in but in
reality what i needed to do was peel
away those outside layers remove the
falseness uncover that mask expose my
broken heart so that i could heal from
within and thus love other people and in
loving other people loving myself even
more
on a lighter note joining some sort of a
martial arts class is very much on my
bucket list when i can afford to not
work full-time but i spent hundreds of
hundreds of dollars no probably
thousands of dollars on aspiring sports
equipment i purchased boxing equipment a
treadmill and other things that i rarely
used i take that back i did use the
treadmill but i find that i get a lot of
value from just simpler things like
hiking going for a walk or doing a hit
workout on my yoga mat in my living room
for now that is all that i really need
and believe me we did not get back the
amount of money that i spent on all of
that live and you learn you guys you
live and you learn
[Music]
these next two things were actually
gifts from my husband but i include them
because it's not his money it's not my
money it's our money and i know that he
purchased them because he knew that i
wanted them and that is an apple watch
and a michael kors watch i love the
style of the michael kors watch i think
it's absolutely beautiful and i enjoy
its beauty i also really like the style
of the apple watch that i had but they
just no longer represent who i am and
what i want from life since i've
embraced the concept of minimalism and
slow and intentional living i just no
longer enjoy wearing flashy clothes and
jewelry and especially when it comes to
technology i want to feel that i am
using it and there's just something
about constantly being attached to that
watch that made me feel a slave to it in
recent years especially in my work as a
hospice nurse constantly working with
people who are at the end stages of life
i have come to value my time so much
more and i long to savor the moments
that i have with my family with my
friends with my patients with whoever i
am around that i can really be present
and so for me it's important to be able
to detach completely from technology but
for me i think it's a much healthier
balance to be able to put my phone away
and it's not uncommon for me to leave it
in a cubby leave it on a shelf for hours
on or even the entire day and i wasn't
able to do that with my watch and it
just it didn't make me feel free it
didn't make me feel like i had that
ability to be present because it was
buzzing it was constantly trying to grab
my attention and so these sorts of
things just no longer work for me i
actually ended up gifting the apple
watch to my mom who really does find a
lot of value from it and i think that
this just goes to show that just because
a purchase that i made was a mistake for
me doesn't mean that it's the same for
you or even vice versa i think that it
all comes down to making sure that the
purchases we're making are intentional
and that they add value to your life so
that this way you can not only have more
money but have more time for the things
that truly the matter most to you in
your life so there you have it those are
my seven worst financial decisions that
i made in my early 20s there are
probably more but maybe next time we can
talk about these smart ones if you like
this video please don't forget to give
it a thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss when i post a new video i
thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to hear from you in the
comments until next time bye